now I want you to think about the
approach that I've been using so far and
then I want you to have a look at why
I'm asking you to stop and pause before
we look at questions like these we were
going to and then I decided to leave it
till today okay there's some real
problems with these guys cause x equals
0 sine x equals zero there are a couple
of problems but the biggest one that I
think is most obvious is this one see
this step in here you can't answer this
question is cos positive or negative is
sine positive or negative because zero
is neither it's not up it's not down
it's it's that special number that isn't
either of those okay so therefore a
different approach is required which is
why and I'd like you to do the same
could you draw a tiny unit circle beside
you're working here for me draw a unit
circle for me now as you do that I'm
going to help you wrap your head around
this new strategy which goes all the way
back to how we redefine the
trigonometric functions we said no more
writing with triangles we said the unit
circle right on the unit circle
what are cos and sine I'll give you a
clue they have something to do with
coordinates what's close close is that
it's alphabetical right it's
alphabetical
so cos is the x-coordinate and sine is
the y-coordinate like that okay does
that make sense okay now if let's do
Part C first
if cos is the x-coordinate if cos is the
X 1 that's about horizontal right so
where on the unit circle has an
x-coordinate then x-coordinate on 0
where on the unit circle okay so the
origin is 0 0 it has an x-coordinate 0
but the problem is it's actually not on
the circle
I'm looking for spots on the
circumference right so therefore I think
that's helpful though look at the spot
above see this guy here that has an
exponent of zero right in fact you know
the whole coordinates what are the whole
coordinates zero right and there's
another one isn't there down the bottom
there's this guy it's zero negative one
okay now think think think both of these
spots have an x-coordinate of zero that
means that cause of I should have said
theta that means that cos is zero at
these points so what are the angles that
go with those that's 90 that's 270 and
sure enough I mean we actually did this
the first time we looked at the unit
circle if you go ahead and grab your
calculator Chuck in cos 90 chuckin cause
270 sure enough you will get zero okay
all right now righty-ho question so for
this one the short answer is no because
what happens is for these we get the
base angle and then we use it in a
quadrant the real reason why this is a
problem is cuz it's not in a quadrant do
you notice that if I had to ask you
which quadrant it's 90 degrees in yeah
it's not in this quadrant all this
quadrant 270 is the same it's not in
this quadrant or this quadrant it's just
kind of there you can't kinda kinda
sorta let's see the last one draw
another unit circle for me just a little
one aha okay so sine X is which
coordinate sine sine is the y coordinate
right that's when is it zero here and
here do you agree hearing you okay so
what's the angle for this the angle for
this guy is zero this is the starting
point what about this one now I want you
to look at all the questions we've done
in solving these some trigonometric
equations so far okay do you notice that
over and
again frequently we get to solutions to
solutions to solutions to solutions okay
just like here when you have a quadratic
you kind of expect two solutions except
if you think you recognize there's
actually a third solution for this one
that's why I left it lost okay
let me show you the the first place you
get this answer zero right when you whip
around to this one that's 180 degrees
and that's where you get this solution
but if you keep going then you end on
360 and where is 360 degrees it's back
where you started
it's back where you started so this
one's a bit weird it's got three
solutions